foreign
the second line he could play center both Wings
he's got a ton of trust from his coach Rick
bonus and he'll hook me up with confetti
and Anita writer in this one not only do
you kill penalties but I think it frees your
team up to play a little bit more closer to
the edge and when you're not terrified to
take the penalty Walker do her directions
with the goal kicked Away by hellebuck Dylan
lost it you're still here with a chance and
that is denied by halibut point blank and
the Jets clear it early in the season and
hellebuck gets his wishes he's doing a good job
stealing the post and this is a tough one right
very little time to react Harkins good Puck
movement Harkins has a trailer it scored in
traffic good pass to hurt it's right in
front of the post he scores [Applause]
Jensen Harkins saw some good work from Parker Ford
gives the Jets the one nothing lead Parker Ford
he's getting himself another game as he got his
first action last game in this building and he's
working real hard here good two on ones given goes
with Jansen Harkins and they work the two-on-one
off the half wall it'll stop up from Ford you can
see how he draws two guys to him someone's open
it's number 12. receives it little and tight move
off the post and in Jansen Harkins a little for a
side action for you as Rudy carries for Calgary
under a minute to go in his first period uyghurt
sedora A Smith move the key to zador off to the
net and stopped there by hellebar fancy footwork
for the big Defender Hunt is on it back Weger
snapshot block gets it back that's block two
open Netflix score Hunt is able to steer it into
the four on four and the Flames have tied it at
one as we mentioned he had a career year last year
with 14 goals how about that that's mccarish as he
spins away from his check and he tries to go far
post comes close and then his teammates follow it
up Dryden hunt gathers the puck and as the Flames
push on they finally find a way to get it in and
behind Conor helbuck I believe this is going to
go to Rooney and the Flames have tied it at once
here with just over 20 seconds to go foreign
for any player to be able to play professional
hockey in front of their children whether they
remember it or not it's pretty neat to see great
footage from the warm-up there is the second
period starts as it's carried ahead by Kevin
Rooney Rooney good pass the door off right in and
he is stopped by Connor hellebuck as Dylan goes
spinning into the corner board you're an office a
defensive demon he was more offensive than Junior
but look at this just find a spot Drive Elaine
and he gets a perfect pass from Rooney right on
the tape he turns the corner that's a big man
if he gets a step on you even Brendan Dylan
wolf stopped it and the Jets have an
offensive zone Face-Off short-handed
he's waiting for the rim from Dylan so watch
he's on the defensive side just hoping for a
hop and he puts himself in a position
to take advantage of that I think it's
he gets the puck now he gets to speed he's got
a two-on-one at decom working against Rooney
and leaving it for Lowry came over to check
him now recentering pass Appleton good save
by wolf he hasn't been that busy tonight that's
one of his better what starts with this really
good Face-Off win from Lowry and that gets
possession early a nice little leave behind
from Hannah line look at Lowry pulls his way in
Takes Two Men on and a little in tight pass to
but I would think that he would want to see
these guys grab onto some some team play and
all the things that they've worked on through
training camp and see if they can get a little
bit faster as a group of four or a group of
five blocking that I have follow again three
minutes into this third period 20 seconds
left in the five on three along range drive
by Ford collected by Halala Peter Rider big
shot four keep it back and frico Chase off a
skeet wolf is there Jets retrieve it one
more time need a rider skates in foreign
[Music] power play and it's 2-1 Winnipeg
what you'd normally see on a five on three
but when they hit a pad or there was a save
they did that really well they retrieved
the puck they got it back and then they
were able to reload reset and re-fire it it
makes you feel good to see a guy like Parker
Ford get rewarded it's the second point of the
game the first one was the assist to Harkins
of course and then that bomb on the flank I
mentioned his workout but he's not very big
but he plays up the icicles need a rider with
the design to grab that Puck and he does you
don't need a writer Adam Lowery Center in pass
rebound and Ford missed the second right there
40 seconds to go with the power play quick
Puck movement now Russia for the leaves and
shoots in a change direction batted Away by uh
salmon and he tried to find it we know he's got
the offense but they're probably more concerned
about playing defense first domesticov is going
to have a break wolf comes out but it is the
best to cop right in stopped by wolf we talked
about it earlier the Jets with so many options
short-handed you mentioned it they had a lot
of opportunities short-handed last year they
were pretty successful how many short-handed
chances will they get this season as it's clear
to the glass but not out Foster lead to zadorov
with a nice move and a nice finish and it's 2-2
has this on a yo-yo this is an excellent job so
he represents shot watch him get it here shot nope
whoop pulls it right out of the lane around Bauer
and then top Corner that is an attractive release
and the Flames off of that shot tie the game
[Music] Connor Zari great look at it there
[Music] [Applause] overtime opening
Face-Off wieger has it for Calgary
Coronado takes that toward the Jets line all three
Winnipeg players and there look out giving it away
is uh and he makes a terrific save Coronado
thought he had the game right there in Sullivan
with a brilliant stop the best of the Night
by any of the three goaltenders now I have
followed for Nino Nina Ryder to the next shot
stopped in Hell by Dustin wolf I'm good with the
opportunity he's been given so we'll fluff there
but you fail your cell phone how about that stop
[Applause] rebound Ford couldn't Snoop it up
click off accepts a feed five seconds domestic
car fans yelling shoot will he domestic call to
the net and his plan expires wolf makes the save
and here he comes [Applause] out white
farm and need a rider kind of Bobble
off the toe of the stick so he misses
the goal yeah he didn't get the shot
off he wanted as he does the fake he wants
wolf to go down and he wants to beat him
blocker side there's the fake and he just
doesn't get it up on that like he wanted to
sorry to score that beautiful goal
earlier in the period here's the
booze takes it over the line drives way wide
sorry nice Maneuvers but Sullivans in no way
it's why it's so important to be a good
skater as a goaltender to be able to track
the puck when it comes from the wall like
this so you have to create your own angle
as a goaltender nice job from Salman and just
to Shadow the puck Parker Ford has a goal and
assists tonight he'd love to have a shootout
throw to that total Ford slows stopped by wolf
back-to-back goaltender of the year in
the American Hockey League back-to-back
goaltender of the year in the Western
Hockey League the CHL goaltender of the
Year back when he was in the Western
Hockey League as well wolf has uh been
there and done that 17 goals last year
comes for the line rather slowly scores
took his time and picked a spot and beats Solomon
that is a sneaky little release so the timing is
one thing and then where he places is just up
over the pad and under the glove tucked it in
on that far side perfectly placed guess my score
latislav domesticov needs this one it's a Time
oh man wolf stayed with it big celebration for
Dustin wolf of the Flames take
it and a shootout three to two